Speaker 1: Let's continue speaking to people from
the audience. We take calls on the Friday show via
Discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord. I
want to go next to Freddy from Monterey. Freddy
from Monterey, welcome to the program. What's
on your mind today? What can I do for you?
Freddy from Monterey.
Speaker 2: Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Hey, thanks for taking my
call. I guess the question I hear in California
and I am going in two weeks to Wisconsin to
a family wedding and I know a very important
election just happened. I believe that was today.
Speaker 1: So earlier this week and Tuesday.
On Tuesday, there was a liberal Supreme Court
justice elected to the Wisconsin Supreme
Court. And this makes the court a liberal
court for the first time in 15 years.
Major implications for abortion rights,
gerrymandering, maybe even the 2024 election.
Speaker 2: Right. Which is great. Yeah, I was
looking at that, the whole gerrymandering thing,
and it's absolutely insane how the Republicans
can do that. But I was just wondering, you know,
I'm going there and I'm realizing that a lot of
the family in law's family that I'm going to be
around probably don't have the same views as me.
And somebody had made a joke about us coming from
California and they were going to let us know of
this and this and this. I just I know you like you
have a little pointers on how I should go about.
What I say, you know, and like, try
not to get into arguments. You know,
it's like my wife's family and stuff.
Speaker 1: We'll hear my suggestions.
I actually wrote a guide about this. And if
you go to David Pakman dot com slash guide,
some people call it a white paper, some
call it a guide. This is free. It's like
ten pages. It's called building arguments
without Burning Bridges. And it'll give you
a lot of ideas. And fundamentally, the
decision you have to make is what sort
of relationship do you want to have with the
folks you're visiting? And that will kind of
inform how confrontational or adversarial you
want to be. But yeah, free guide available on
that topic. David Pakman dot com slash guide.
Speaker 2: Oh, great. That's cool. Okay. Yeah,
just I mean, I'm pretty excited about, you know,
the results that happened over there and I'm like,
Oh, yeah, I'm going to Wisconsin, this is great.
But then I'm like, Oh, should I show how excited
I am? I got to just play it by ear, I guess.
Speaker 1: I think that's the smartest thing.
Speaker 2: All right, cool. Well, that's about it.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks very much. Got a lot
going on there and headed to Wisconsin very soon,
which I'm sure will be a very, very powerful trip